In the 21 years since author J.K.
Rowling published the first entry into what
would become the wildly successful Harry Potter
book series, fans have concocted some pretty
far-out theories.
There was the infamous one from 2004 that
argued the freckle-faced Ron Weasley was actually
Albus Dumbledore traveling back in time.
There was the suggestion that Professor Minerva
McGonagall wasn't the trustworthy, kind, and
wise Head of Gryffindor everyone knew her
as, but was actually a Death Eater.
There was even a Reddit fan theory that claimed
Ginny Weasley made love potions in the sixth
book, Harry Potter and the Half-Blood Prince,
and used them to induce Harry's feelings of
intense infatuation for her.
While Rowling hasn't been shy about addressing
fan theories in the past, there's one she
hasn't touched on until now – and it's one
Harry Potter fans have long suspected to be
true.
These days, everybody knows how to pronounce
the name of Hogwarts' feistiest little wizard.
Hermione
Harry! Hermione
Ms. Granger
But before 2000, it wasn't exactly common
knowledge.
On Twitter, one user theorized that Rowling
included the passage about how to properly
pronounce Hermione Granger's name in the fourth
book, Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire,
"just to school all of us who were saying
HER-MY-OWN like Viktor Krum."
After Viktor repeatedly refers to her as "Hermy-own,"
"You're saying it wrong"
Hermione clarifies that her name is actually
pronounced "Her-my-oh-nee."
I shouldn't have said that I shouldn't have
said that."
When Harry Potter fans first read The Goblet
of Fire back when it was originally published
in 2000, they probably took the scene as little
more than a slightly awkward, but mostly chuckle-worthy
moment between the incredibly intelligent
Hermione and Viktor.
As time went on, however, more and more readers
started to believe that the conversation had
a double meaning and served to subtly inform
fans about how to say Hermione's name the
correct way.
Once Rowling caught wind of the theory, she
simply responded, "Theory correct."
"I can't believe it, she's done it again."
Sure, the theory isn't as bizarre as the ones
we mentioned before, but it's long been a
popular one amongst Potterheads.
And it's a good thing that Rowling tossed
the small moment into The Goblet of Fire,
since it appears that countless Harry Potter
fans were saying Hermione's name all wrong
until she gave Viktor a pronunciation lesson.
The Twitter account for the fan site Wizarding
News posted after Rowling confirmed the theory:
"I'm embarrassed it took three and a half
books to learn that pronunciation.
Like many others, I had never seen the name
Hermione before in my life.
Definitely pronounced it HER-ME-OWN in my
head for far too long."
"Honestly, don't you two read?"
Another Twitter user shared that she didn't
even know Hermione's name was Hermione because
her parents couldn't pronounce the character's
name when reading her the book at bedtime.
"The most prominent memory I have of my parents
reading Harry Potter to me before bed is my
dad going 'Well that's a stupid name, from
now own I'm going to call her…
Jane.'"
"Soon we must all face a choice between what
is right and what is easy."
Thankfully, a year after Viktor got all tongue-tied
in The Goblet of Fire, which was published
in 2000, fans got to hear Emma Watson say
Hermione Granger's name in the first Harry
Potter movie.
Ever since, there haven't been many mispronunciations.